今日は自宅警備員はず3冊ですお前ら
命の危険を感じたことはないか今は世界のどこにいても家
なんでこんなの買ったからするあれああ
今は地球のどこにいてもいつ誰が襲いかかってきてもわからないネットワーク社会に
なりつつある今の現代において少しの犬1人が品でもない兵器をかきおこさんあるんだ
そこで私はもしまず仮に俺が家に僕はこれそうですが暗殺者が入ってきたときにいかに
して戦うかおそらくなんですけど僕多分その
戦闘力ないんでまず張るほどきたら親父に多分普通にやられておりますありがとう
ございましたなのでここはちょっとね知恵を働かせて立てるんじゃなくて歯くれようか
と思います
なぜ自宅にヤバイ奴が入り込んだ時に僕は一貫して隠れるかということを考えたとき
ランボール用ダンボール
ダンボールあめっちゃ買う言えないは段ボールを利用しようかなと思います今回はダン
ボールを利用したステルスルームを作り家の皆さんにご紹介しようと思います
自宅警備員の皆かーっよくわかると思うんですけど大量の段ボール詰めして私は今から
全然近くしてお部屋絶対歌うボール箱って埋め尽くしますかいや
太陽がボス襲撃者がくるので襲撃者にボケ月のダンボール
捨てる弦いたらバレないかどうかと言うとか貯金刑事のになぜに関わる大事な紛レん
ですもう誰たら終わったくらいで必要でまず出る事例をつけていこう
待ってくれ
voodoo
ita アイティー
完成しましたこれがかーぼーずてすぐです場ダートのカープ
これ何が翔太と簡単な牙でに埋め尽くした暖房
これがきたでしょ後ろも全部ダンボールでございますはい q これからターゲットが
来るんですけどもうやるかやられるかの一気勝負見つかったし
が僕はもう
かなのでちょっとねほんとにかなり僕は本気でありますもうすぐターゲットが来るの僕
はこの段ボールの中のどれかに入っています3分くらいかな散歩稲荷見つかれば僕は
文字へ3分が生き残ってれば僕のかつです今まで使ってきた大勃起確実番禺が多いです
から守る多くがこれまで捨てずに取っておいた版ポル全部でシェアして僕を見つける
ことができるんでしょ
あーでは hyde いいん
はいといけもうすぐ来ると思うので僕はダンボールに隠れます
どうするどうすよ
まあどこにかければいいだろ隠れる場所がわからまず増加系です
人は俗にてましょうカンタンに使われていないから俺もやってもいいの好きな
やるかやられるかな一騎打ちひるんでらんねーぜ
たりしますね
4日
ああああああ
ています
tee
me
いいいい
ああああああ
ええええええ
me
います
ございます
はぁ
ええええええ
すっっ
おっし
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ええええええ
car
嘘だッ
love me
ああああああ
ええええええ
ん
mar
はぁ
ああああああ
なぜここが分かった俺はプロスナ ever
な例じゃなぜが先日だよねー
war い
というゲスてレース山潜ってるプルームでした
あっはぁ
car